presenti ragazzi e bentornati sul mio
canale oggi siamo tornati su jovan
folpetti col buon pietro il buon stesso
dalle o la cosa divertente che l'altra
mappa che abbiamo fatto la quale il golf
oggi facciamo quella della sila
cyberpunk e ormai fatti secondo me il ps
vanno meglio qua va bè cosa vedo aspetta
non schiacciare il tasto perché non
conta sono questo portava solo o addio
dal niente sono l'unico che non è
arrivato
ragazzi questa idea di intelligenza noi
siamo fregati allora è finita mettere la
palla a quaglia devo spingerla no guarda
miti da qua però non so con che criterio
cioè senza pungere anche a mano quella
balla con la palla l'avevamo la palla in
più bella quella bolla è breve
games è bloccato adesso provvedere
trasmette aspetta ma non credo che
allora ma è pesantissima questa palla è
perché quella era veramente pesante ok
togli vai bene è vero di berretti
l'elogio artissima
poi secondo me abbiamo fatto un secondo
ce la facciamo un po di un'ora e mezza
mamma mia ragazzi
no la cosa ma no perché l'altra volta da
jerry prima ecco la mamma mia ke ridere
che nuovamente stavo morendo da perché
quando su vieni e la cosa piu lustra
quale legare il giallo a posto finito ma
ecco i premi e quello gira devi spingere
quindi bravo hai dato dove la prima
stesso allora la nuova un portone no
questo non si perché vende non ci serve
più questo la fai fare a noi le cose
intelligenti sicuramente serve anche
questo è troppo intelligente il livello
di oggi però no infatti sono tranne
usando 2000 e di cupertino non solo
capendo in dubbio per la gara
spingere come solo messo ai leggerissimo
l'omesso aspetta che primo febbraio è
uno andato bravissimi manca l'altro mi
sembra un po storto con di pietro ci
potrebbe esserci un problema di
stabilità in questa cosa non tranquillo
il suo gioco non è tutto proprio stabile
schiaccia l'altro se quelle citate ok
mamma mia ragazzi to perfetto mi ha
detto ragazzi mi aspetto le note che la
migliore poi primo nora che dobbiamo
dare in qualche punto in alto non so
dove
ma curva e nocivo no ma conosci addio
la città è gigantesca arrivo che stiamo
andando però va beh non lo so me lo
sposto regala deve aver esposto per sé
un parkour che si muove avere un
atteggiamento possa fare questo guarda
temo amici io che faccio qui sotto
cadendo
sono contento tu non fare niente aspetta
coltivato una tiro non tiriamo una leva
che non so cosa serve ma io non prenderà
me compreso terre cadiamo tutti i tuoi
così da ridere non si tira ok scoperto
sento dei rumori brutti anch'io
sta arrivando una gru da sempre di te
cosa ho visto cose da bottone leva bay
pietro lasciamoli non abbiamo mandato
pieno entrambi lasciano nel problema è
arrivato soltanto c'è il sailing non c'e
neanche ce in poi da successo che saving
amici arrivo note per ricarica
bellissimo oddio l'ho fatto per omar
estrae mamma mia mamma mia mamma mia
bruce a chi aprile arriva dal centro
nome ragazzi abbiamo già fatto bastava
farne uno e poi di ben poi non lo sanno
ancora ma non gioco più divertente e non
avevo capito che fosse finito ma semmai
una brutta persona palermo e rimanere
io ho preso quello scelto per sbaglio io
a di fare un altro parco cioè un altro
di quelli dove sapeva bene ninjawords ce
l'ho fatta a salutare credevo che per
far parte devo credere io
osserviamo ce l'ha fatta ce l'ho fatta
ho fatto sono fermati volta e non c'è un
bottone non è quindi fare deve farmi
stavano tirando che ci arrivo ci sono
arrivati tecnico mamma mia ragazzi
impossibile
una bruttissima notizia boruc c'è di
nuovo il bowling e con noi questo bike
non creandomi non credo nel ducato
finché pietro lancia mamma mia
io vado qua sopra lo farò un parkour non
so tali per cui per far virare la
pallina vi sarà quelle butti giù per
fuori le palle in un attimo che la vedo
un po difficile
mamma mia ragazzi guarda la mamma mia ce
l'ho fatta provaci provaci veramente
difficile bisogna fare strike riguardano
strike ed io non ci credo è nata
attenzione dallo non lo so no non è
stata perfetta che vuol dire veramente
perfetta pet aspetta aspetta aspetta
aspetta aspetta non farlo non partire
sono partito guarda c'è la lancer
lancerà la tattica ma si sta sta venendo
ce l'ha fatta
sono di alto livello dopo sono a livello
dopo non ho parole
parliamo veramente fortissimo non ci
credo non ci credo non so neanche dove
andare io no ma non è possibile fare ti
attacchi al martello attaccati al suo
martello con cavalli e non solo perché
mi sa che dovete fare per forza perché
poi deve scattare sta a fare se non
scatta mamma no way
mamma mia che i giocatori
ma non mi ha mai fatto sognare dopo di
avere mezza matta pagando tutto è
possibile ma devo andare a bravissimi
medica era un tunnel spazio temporale
come potevo saperlo io sono arrivato per
cerchi di barare
chi siamo veramente
belle cose scale comunque questo livello
no ma volevo andare anch'io piena regola
futura va bene dove stava andando 650
arrivo non c'è conti ci pensa di andare
perché sono in uno show
ai ragazzi non capisco cosa sia ma c'è
un sacco di roba dice un uomo
l'evento nel tubo ma sono andati a masi
catinali ragazzi sono troni e un drone
che vola devi andare da qualche parte ho
capito devi bipolare tra un ipad napoli
è in mezzo ci sono cose che ti spingono
in alto
ebbene la spiegazione di che dai sei
utilissima cosa vuoi è difficile parlare
italiano dove in lincoln e sailor e
quello rosa ma e non lo vedo anche
quello il fatto che cosa che non mi
torna
devi spaccarlo pietro si spacca al viola
spacca al viola ma tutti bisogna
spaccare anche quegli altri se seguiamo
semplicemente per sbloccare possono
spaccare
facchino io spacco gli altri io spacco
arancione a spaccare io manca il verde
che qua la squadra tutto è andato è
andato a contorno è fighissimo soggiorno
di controllo eccoti ti vedo ti vedo dai
rotto per la comunità si è aperto di
mollo nel vuoto mamma mia
ad altissima ragazzo bellissimo
praga è stata veramente una purga però
bellissimo bellissimo che livello super
avete seguito ragazzi diverso pietro e
stef perché questo stesso team di
bowling migliore del mondo spero di
vincere un campionato mondiale ma siamo
un buon punto gli scritti anche loro
canaletto line descrizione tranne pietro
che non fa più vita era ci vediamo quasi
non mi piace è stato un momento
recitiamo ragazzi
[Musica]
no